فرغ من سحاب القوات الروسيه منها اكد
الكريملين الا تغير على وضع مدينتي خرسان
جنوب اوكرانيا وانا ضمن الاقاليم الاربعه
التي ضمتها روسيا الى اراضيها اواخر
سبتمبر الماضي في المقابل كيف رحبت
بالانسحاب الروسي واصفه مياه بانه نصر مهم
فيما بدا الجيش الاوكراني بدخول المدينه
مطالبه للجنود الروس المتبقين هناك
بالاستسلام
للمزيد معنا فيها الاستوديو
زميلنا في غرفه الاخبار كبيره المراسلين
عمار حميداوي اهلا وسهلا بك عمار عمار انت
عائد من
اوكرانيا من جبهه القتال همم كنت في منطقه
غير بعيده من خرسون هل كان هذا القرار
مفاجئا من قبل القوات الروسيه بالانسحاب
من خرسون
همم بالنسبه للكثير من المتابعين وكذلك
بالنسبه للقاده العسكريين الاوكرانيين
الذين كانوا همم يعني يحجون القوه بالقرب
من منطقه خرسون لتحضير لما يسمى بعمليه
تحرير منطقه خرسون من الغزوه الروسي هذا
الاستعداد همم امتد لمده ثلاثه اشهر كنا
قد دعانا انا برفقه الزميل جنى تقدم
القوات الاوكرانيه في هذه المنطقه الفاصله
بين منطقه
خرسون الجميع كان يتوقع ان تكون هناك
معركه شتويه معركه الشتاء خاصه القوات
الروسيه تجيد الح في هذا كذا ظروف
الاوكرانيون كانوا يتوقعون بان القوات
الروسيه تريد ان تستدرج القوات الاوكرانيه
لهكذا نوع من المعارك حتى ان اخر التقارير
التي كانت قد صدرت عن استخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه تشير الى ان القوات الروسيه
كانت قد دعمت مركز مدينه خيرسون بقوات
روسيه متمارسه من البحريه الروسيه وكذلك
من الكوماندو لكن قبل همم اسبوعين تقريبا
قبل او 10 ايام كان هناك حديث من بالنسبه
لتحرك القوات الروسيه من منطقه خرسون جاء
هذا التصريح على لسان القائد العسكري
للمنطقه همم الروسيه القائد العسكري
الروسي المسيطر على المنطقه لكن القوات
الاوكرانيه والقاده العسكريون الاوكرانيون
تعاملوا مع هذا التصريح الذي يشير الى
امكانيه انسحاب القوات الروسيه من الخرسون
بانه نوع من انواع الخدع العسكريه او هو
نوع من المصيه القوات الروسيه ربما لجلبها
خطوطي مدافع القوات الروسيه التي تنتشر في
هذه المنطقه لكن المفاجاه الكبرى هي هذه
التي نعيشها الان خاصه والدخول القوات
الاوكرانيه الى مركز مدينه خرسون لاحظنا
منذ صباح اليوم ارتفاع الاعلام الاوكرانيه
على عده مباني حكوميه في منطقه خرسون في
القرى وكذلك في مركز المدينه وهنالك
استعداد شعبي كبير لاستقبال القوات
الاوكرانيه داخل مركز مدينه غزه
كيف كانت تقوم القاتله الاوكرانيه بالدفاع
عن المدن التي لم تسيطر على عليها القوه
الروسيه او تحاول المدن التي سيطرت عليها
قوه روسيا هل تعتقد ان روسيا ستقوم با
هجوم المضاد لاستعاده خلصنا بعد الانسحاب
منها همم هناك الكثير خاصه روسيا تحاول
ايضا ربما همم يعني همم استعاده ماء الوجه
وحفظ ماء الوجه خاصه بعد الخساره في منطقه
الدنبا كانت تركز على منطقه خرسون واستعدت
لمعركه ما في منطقه خرسون اذن هناك شكوك
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه نحن لاحظنا كيف
ان القوات الاوكرانيه كانت تواجه مصعب
كبيره في التقدم باتجاه منطقه خرسون خاصه
وان القوات الروسيه كانت دعمت خطوط السد
على طوال الطريق الرابط بين ميكو لايف
ومنطقه خرسون هناك اكثر من 20 كيلو متر
تحولت الى ساحه حرب تامه كانت القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول التقدم مترا بعد متر
وذلك يصرعوبه
كانت القوات الروسيه تستخدم المدفعيه
وكذلك الطائرات المسيره والقذف الصاروخي
المستمر على القوات الاوكرانيه حاله
انكشاف الاهداف خاصه وانها كانت معركه
مواقع في هذه المنطقه كنا انا وزميل سنه
برفقه الفرقه 59 المدرعه كانوا يواجهون
مصاعب كبيره في التقدم لكنهم كانوا
باستمرار يحاولون التقدم تحضيره لما يسمى
كان يسمى بمعركه
تحرير خلصون من السيطره الروسيه شكرا
جزيلا لك عمار الحميده وكبير المرسلين
شكرا جزيلا